hello everybody and welcome back to the
third video in the image recognition and
manipulation tutorial series where we
left off we are looking at that array
and in this video we're going to take a
bit more closer look at it again and
explain a few more things in the array
and then we'll go ahead and get started
with actual manipulation and stuff so
here's the array again and just to say
it again the whole thing is the image
broken down is the rows right these are
the rows then you've got each pixel in
that row and it's you know horizontal
right pixel pixel and each number within
here corresponds to red green blue and
then this is your alpha and again alpha
is like fade basically or how solid is
that that picture so if so color rather
so if you have a very low alpha it's
very see-through right transparent
that's the word I'm looking for
transparent it's anyway that's what
alpha is now the next thing that we
might want to consider is why 255 what
the heck is that talking about well in
programming everything is is counted not
starting at one but it starts at zero so
actually these are all 256 so this just
means the image was saved as a 256 color
bitmap not to be confused with like a
256 bit image right so so like if you
think about a 16 color bitmap that means
it only allows like 0 to 15 so 16 total
colors which is actually quite a few
colors so that if a 16 color bitmap will
give you as many as 4096 colors 256
colors will give you obviously a much
larger rikes it's basically your options
are 16 times 16 times 16 right so that
makes 4096 with 256 colors it's 256 x
256 x 256 which gives you basically
sixteen point eight million colors that
you can choose from so obviously there's
a lot more depth to your colors but I'll
be also
honest with you if you look like a like
a non zoomed in picture and one uses the
16 by 16 by 16 right so 16 color bitmap
versus the 256 color bit matte even
though there's it right a massive
difference in colors it's kind of hard
to tell the difference anyways but
that's neither here nor there but I'm
just explaining what these numbers are
so moving right along next question that
a lot of people are going to have is why
is this RGB and not our WB all right WP
you know why is it not our WB that's a
good Chris and why is it not red white
and blue anyway why is it our G B and
not or why be having a really hard time
putting that out right so why is it you
know aren't we taught like an art class
right three primary colors that make all
the other colors red yellow blue right
so are we right red group RGB is red
green blue why are we doing that well a
little bit of history for you guys and I
bet some of you guys probably know but
it was down to the difference between
additive colors versus subtractive
colors now what we're dealing with is
additive colors so as you add more of
that color it actually like makes it
brighter so to speak whereas if you
consider like back in art right in paint
class if you had a green right so you
were painting some green and you paint a
stripe of green and then you paint
another stripe of green over that
previous stripe it makes it a darker
green not a lighter green and but if you
took like a flashlight and you put over
like a green let's say saran wrap that
was green and you turn on that
flashlight and then you've got another
flashlight did the same thing it would
make that green brighter right I want to
make it darker by adding more so it's
the addition of light behind it so
that's why I like well first of all like
white has all of the colors in it right
so pure white we know this is white
because it's 255 255 so it's all of red
olive green and are all of blue right so
we know this this is actually white and
it's a solid white not that even alpha
white wouldn't make a difference but
anyway
unless it was laid over something I
suppose so
and that's why like sunlight for example
is mostly white because it has all of
the colors in it and that's why it is
it's an additive right and conversely
right we've got zero zero zero this
means there's nothing nothing and
nothing there is nothing there and it's
got a full alpha so it's a solid you
guessed it black so so that is additive
versus subtractive colors and then the
reason why we're using this in computers
now you could do it either way really
computers because it's just straight up
just generating this stuff but it just
kind of makes sense to make it additive
instead of subtractive color schemes
because your everything you do on the
computer you're viewing it through a
monitor and the monitor is basically a
light that is shining this stuff to you
so so that's kind of why we're using RGB
so the more you know so the next thing
that I would like to do is this was just
dot right so we see 0 0 0 255 and then
we've got all these other 255 so if we
close out of this and I think I stuck it
in that file let's let me pull that up
real quick the images yeah sure did so
in the images file we had dot and then
there's also dot and dot so if you go
edit that you should get this and then
if you zoom in you'll see there's one
black dot and then there's this one
green dot and let me just grab the
pencil and come over here to the green I
use this green so if we edited that
color we can actually see down here the
red green and blue value of this green
dot so it's 34 1 77 76 so if we close
out of this and just remember it's dot
and dot and we change this to not dot
dot PNG but dot and dot dot PNG run it
and come over here scroll back to the
top here we still have that black dot
right and then we'll sure enough about
34 1 77 76 and then a full alpha so
obviously solid green so I realized to
some of you guys that might sound might
have been like painfully slow and you
already knew everything I just told you
but if you're uncomfortable with the
idea of transferring an image
arrey right and in some array of red
green blue and alpha at first that's
very confusing and you've got to kind of
situate yourself to look at this and see
it right so unless you're from the
matrix you probably don't like look at
this array and you're like okay I see
that it's a black dot in a green dot
right but now now I'm slowly converting
you guys and pretty soon you'll be able
to look at an array and just be able to
see the image you know so you don't even
need images anymore you just need the
arrays you just like look at and be like
that is beautiful that's a good idea I
bet you could do like computer artwork
or something right and just make it the
array and then put like the array up on
the wall and make people look at it
that's just beautiful anyway I bet
there's someone that really can like
look at the array and know what the
picture is but not me anyway so it's
going to conclude this video as always
thanks for watching thanks for your
support your subscriptions and until
next time